hallo meine lieben law is yours
deutschland ist komm ich aus sagt der
meisten ausnahmen und macht heute mit
lukas einbürgerungstest es gibt fünf
verschiedene einbürgerungstest und zwar
einmal standard leicht mittel schwer und
sehr schwer gstaad mit dem standard test
machen hier erst mal ein paar fragen
also sandra das wahlsystem in
deutschland ist ein zensus wahlrecht
drei klassen wahlrecht mehrheits und
verhältniswahlrecht oder ein allgemeines
männer wahlrecht mehrheits und
verhältniswahl freunde wollen in ein
öffentliches schwimmbad in deutschland
beide haben eine dunkle hautfarbe und
werden deshalb nicht hineingelassen
welches recht wird in dieser situation
verletzt das recht auf meinungsfreiheit
gleichbehandlung versammlungsfreiheit
oder freizügigkeit
freizügigkeit weil jeder darf nackt
rumlaufen
es ist vergleichbar gleichbehandlung ist
das was bekommen wahlberechtigte bürger
und bürgerinnen in deutschland vor einer
wahl eine wahlbenachrichtigung von der
gemeinde eine wahl erlaubnis vom
bundespräsidenten beziehungsweise der
bundespräsidentin eine benachrichtigung
von der bundesversammlung oder eine
benachrichtigung vom pfarramt müssen
dies gab der bundespräsident schreibt
uns ein mann möchte mit 30 jahren in
deutschland sein abitur nachholen
[Musik]
wo kann er das tun an einer hochschule
einem abendgymnasium eine hauptschule
oder einer privatuniversität hauptschule
gibt kein abitur das weiß ich genau
haben gemerkt dass auch richtig denn die
du hast das ja alles richtig was ist
eine aufgabe der polizei in deutschland
das land zu verteidigen
die bürgerinnen und bürger abzuhören die
gesetze zu beschließen oder die
einhaltung von gesetzen zu überwachen
nicht abhören dass es macht nämlich
schon die nsa gesetze beschließen was
angelo mehr dafür ganz genau es ist
falsch
die polizei verteidigt und nicht unser
land doch die kontrollieren dass die
gesetze gegen ich würde allerdings mal
sagen dass wir jetzt von dem standard
test weg gehen zu dem leichten tag also
der ist sogar noch leichter als die
hölle
welches land ist ein nachbarland von
deutschland ist es spanien bulgarien
norwegen oder luxemburg luxemburg weil
da muss man keine steuern
[Musik]
was bedeutet die abkürzung cdu in
deutschland christliche deutsch für
union club deutscher unternehmer
christlicher deutscher umweltschutz oder
christlich demokratische union
schwere frage
[Musik]
christlich deutsche union ist falsch
wirklich demokratische union regal
nächste frage in deutschland hat man die
besten chance auf einen gut bezahlten
arbeitsplatz wenn man abitur
wenn man katholisch ist wenn man gut
ausgebildet ist wenn man eine frau ist
oder wenn man mitglied einer partei ist
was sollten sie tun wenn sie von ihrem
ansprechpartner beziehungsweise ihre
ansprechpartnerin in einer deutschen
behörde schlecht behandelt werden
ich kann nichts tun ich muss mir diese
behandlung gefallen lassen ist rohe der
person oder ich kann mich bei dem
behördenleiter oder bei der
behördenleiterin beschweren
ganz leicht oder person alter menschen
in deutschland leben nach dem grundsatz
der religiösen toleranz was bedeutet
dass es dürfen keine moscheen gebaut
werden alle menschen glauben an gott
jeder kann glauben was er möchte oder
der staat entscheidet an welchen gott
die menschen glauben
gewährt der staat entscheiden welchen
gott die menschen
das ist also jeder kann glauben was er
möchte ja ja ja das ist auch wieder
richtig nächste frage welches gericht
ist in deutschland bei konflikten in der
arbeitswelt zuständig das
familiengericht das strafgericht das
arbeitsgericht oder das amtsgericht
ist halt lustig weil es die frage selbst
eigentlich schon bald fortsetzt wenn
seine einbürgerung ist jetzt so einfach
ist das arbeitsgericht ist auf jeden
fall richtig sandra und ich würde sagen
jetzt kommen auch schon zur letzten
frage für den leichten test welche
religion hat die europäische und
deutsche kultur geprägt der hinduismus
das christentum der buddhismus oder der
islam richtig sandra das christentum
kommen jetzt die mittelschwere die
volkshochschule in deutschland ist eine
einrichtung für das religion hatte in
religion unterrichten nur für
jugendliche zur weiterbildung oder nur
für rentner und rentnerinnen ganzglas er
dass es richtig sandra nächste frage
ausländische arbeitnehmer und
arbeitnehmerinnen die in den 50er und
60er jahren von der bundesrepublik
deutschland angeworben wurden nannte man
schwarzarbeiter gastarbeiter
zeitarbeiter oder schichtarbeiter
schwarzarbeiter weil ja noch kein
deutsch
das sind zeitarbeiter
zeitarbeiter sind es nicht gastarbeiter
ja das war ein test ob du mit direkt zu
stimmen was ist kein bundesland der
bundesrepublik deutschland
nordrhein-westfalen elsass lothringen
metal
ich kann das nicht mal aussprechen ist
das los den ganzen mann baute die ddr
die mauer in berlin ok 1919 33 61 oder
90 das ist klar dicker ist als rasen
1999 wurde die mauer geschlossen
also haben wir die kaputt gemacht
ich war gar nix ich sage 61 egal welchen
fest tragen menschen in deutschland
bunte kostüme und masken am rosenmontag
ab welchen worten die deutsche
nationalhymne völker hört die signale
einigkeit und recht und freiheit freude
schöner götterfunke oder deutschland
einig vaterland
sandra richter beziehungsweise eine
richterin gehört in deutschland zur
vollziehenden gewalt recht sprechenden
gewalt planenden gewalt oder
gesetzgebenden gewalt von easy warum ist
das der schwere einbürgerungs
vollziehende gewalt wenn das ist falsch
was steht nicht im grundgesetz von
deutschland die würde des menschen ist
unantastbar alle sollen gleich viel geld
haben jeder mensch darf seine meinung
sagen oder alle sind vor dem gesetz
gleich
nicht allen gleich viel geld sehr gut
ist auch richtig welche der folgenden
auflistung hält nur bundesländer die zum
gebiet der früheren ddr gehörten
niedersachsen nordrhein-westfalen hessen
schleswig-holstein brandenburg
mecklenburg vorpommern brandenburg
sachsen sachsen-anhalt und thüringen
bayern baden württemberg rheinland pfalz
thüringen und sachsen oder sachsen
thüringen hessen niedersachsen und
brandenburg
da kann ich nur worten ich kann auch nur
raten ehrlich gesagt wir sagen wir sagen
ja okay was ist richtig
warum nennt man die zeit im herbst 1989
in der ddr die wende in dieser zeit
veränderte sich die ddr politisch von
einer diktatur zur demokratie von einer
liberalen marktwirtschaft zum
sozialismus von einer monarchie zur
sozialdemokratie oder von einem
religiösen staat zu einem
kommunistischen staat
das ist auch easy ich weiß es aber wir
sind jetzt demokratie
sally kombi nun allerdings auch schon
zur letzten der fünf stufen und zwar zum
sehr schweren test bereit
je mehr zweitstimmen eine partei bei
einer bundestagswahl bekommen desto mehr
sitze erhält die partei im parlament
desto weniger erststimmen kann sie haben
desto mehr direktkandidaten der parteien
ins parlament ein oder desto größer ist
das risiko eine koalition bilden zu
müssen
die
was das so selbstbewusst gesagt die
deutschen bundesländer wirken an der
gesetzgebung des bundes mit durch den
bundesrat die bundesversammlung den
bundestag oder die bundesregierung
ich glaube die regierung weil die hat am
meisten zu sorgen
es ist falsch der bundesrat was macht
der bundesrat
genau
teilen wurde 1946 zwangsweise zu spd
vereint der einheitspartei der späteren
ddr kpd und spd spd und cdu cdu und fdp
oder kpd und csu
das heißt also ich kenne die spd und die
cdu die cdu und die fdp kann ich okay
was mich zu nehmen
sie ist falsch
was ist denn kpd katholische partei
deutschland kommunistische partei
deutschlands
wann wurde die bundesrepublik
deutschland gegründet 1939 1945 1949
es hat etwas zu tun mit den zwei mehr
oder weniger ja 1945 war er kriegt ja
oben deswegen 45 945 denkst du dir sagen
direkt nach dem krieg sollte mir eins
oder was an der stelle würden zehn ihm
nicht das heutige bietet allerdings
agenten meine lieben freunde wenn euch
der einbürgerungstest hier mit seinem
ball gefallen hat dann das gerne einen
daumen hoch unter diesem video hier da
sein was kann alles und in der video
beschreibung verlinkt die lebt jetzt
dreimal wöchentlich videos hoch also
schaut gerne ihr vorbei und schloss die
letzten sechs worte du sollte demnächst
den schnabel erhalten
das waren wirklich weg wörter
[Musik]